[Music]
I love to play with human bodies because
everyone can connect with it
everyone is everyone is a human saying
that they like the way I'm sinking
because the kids are a little bit
different then not is not so obvious I'm
trying to - it's obvious like because
today social media channels you scroll
down and everything is like see
sometimes everything smokes it's nothing
that's why I'm using also this fully
light monotone Colossus 20 if I would
use dark stuff everyone would say this
is disgusting the watch it
[Music]
was basically to learn the speedy
program which I'm working on mostly and
this 3d program is really good for
simulations and we have like I was also
coming home revving up was what we look
for our two koreas just to learn
something when I started every clip was
like a challenge in terms of setup and I
really I realized really fast and it is
smaller than just a technical test
[Music]
and now it's basically like business at
the same time when I posting something
there are tons of comment and we felt
automatically and then I can square it
and just wait if I post something I can
rate the next two days drop requests
from big companies you know what you're
doing before you start because that
simulates a woolly time consuming so for
five second clip you sometimes need a
nose we have four days to get it
perfectly because simulations are really
hard to a direct and a little bit luck
it's like like a game a puzzle this is
this program and it's fun and work at
the same time
[Music]